the castle hello what the hell is this  lithium load is that my mom is that my  mom hey princess hi son yeah what they  I'll have me throw you back out again oh  I was out on the golf course and I told  you to watch that backswing no he was  hit by a car it just fell out of the sky  you could have been killed and I was 2  under par I don't know what this world  is coming to Marty how was work  Oh mom I'm telling you that big  promotion is just around the corner  anyway I'm starving let's see go on son  let's go it's dinner time and I'm  watching these programs mister we eat at  the dinner table when your grandparents  are here put your damn glasses on huh  dad I can only watch 2 is chosen once on  these things yeah you kids really got it  rough When I was your age I wanted to  watch two shows at once I had to put two  sets next to each other